[Música]
fue un incendio accidental en una
discoteca y provocó la caída de un
gobierno la tragedia en el colectivo que
sacudió a la capital rumana cinco años
desencadenó la ira pública con miles de
personas saliendo a las calles el 30 de
octubre de 2015 los que asistieron a
bailar divertirse y escuchar un
concierto en el club nocturno de
bucarest se encontraron atrapados en un
infierno sin salidas de emergencia al
menos 27 personas murieron pero ese
número se duplicó durante las próximas
semanas debido en parte al deteriorado
sistema de salud humanos con hospitales
sucio desinfectante diluido para ahorrar
dinero y escasos recursos médicos para
hacer frente a la situación algunos
heridos incluso tuvieron que ser
enviados al extranjero y con el paso de
los días también se iba conociendo
información negativa sobre los
propietarios del club nocturno y por
ejemplo que habían escatimado en medidas
de seguridad priorizando las finanzas
qué lecciones han aprendido cinco años
después de esta tragedia
empezamos boleto de vuelta
mi hija y es un sobreviviente hace cinco
años grababa el concierto cuando el club
collective se incendió gravemente
quemado pasó varias semanas entre la
vida y la muerte
cada 30 de octubre conmemora los
desaparecidos en bucarest algunos eran
cercanos a él
y no me siento muy bien cuando estoy
aquí porque cuando veo este lugar
recuerdo escenas había muchas
ambulancias aquí era una pesadilla
[Música]
un sismo más que una pesadilla porque el
incendio le prendió fuego a todo el país
incompetencia soborno el club nunca
debió haber abierto pero el escándalo no
se limita a una sala de conciertos y
normas de seguridad el estado rumano
gangrenado por la corrupción fue incapaz
de curar a sus heridos las familias aún
siguen atormentadas por una pregunta
cómo se llegó a eso
lawrence yo extra te perdió a su hijo de
22 años que murió en el hospital después
del incendio al igual que otras 34
personas sin embargo está convencido de
que pudo haberse salvado para mí hay una
responsabilidad del estado
su vida se interrumpió demasiado pronto
a causa de ese sistema no lo olvidaré
jamás el estado no abrió ninguna
investigación para entender lo que había
pasado en el hospital
van a poner fotos de las víctimas en las
escaleras de la corte podemos ir y
después volver aquí
imaginen
[Música]
al igual que para los otros
sobrevivientes para mi hija y el combate
por la verdad que empezó el día
siguiente del drama está lejos de
haberse terminado
estas son las fotos de todas las
personas que murieron después del
colectivo actor colectivo es un
happening pero es una pérdida de sentido
es un mensaje para la justicia tras el
era en el juicio porque la verdad es muy
importante para las víctimas para sus
familias y también para todo el país
[Música]
cinco años después aprendió el país
lecciones de esta tragedia nada es menos
seguro
[Música]
empleados municipales el jefe del club
el pirotécnico los responsables del
incendio fueron condenados a penas de
cárcel pero siguen libres apelaron el ex
alcalde del distrito fue reelegido en el
mes de septiembre a pesar de su condena
de ocho años y medio de cárcel
[Música]
entra por favor esta mañana adrián álbum
tiene una cita con su abogado imposible
renunciar a la justicia para este
sobreviviente del collective que vio
morir a su hermana
en dos días habrá una nueva audiencia
para presentar todas las pruebas
al cabo de tres semanas mi hermana había
muerto en un hospital y espero que las
personas responsables por su muerte
vayan a la carga de gasteiz quedó
pitando del delta no se le puede hacer
justicia a los muertos que están más
allá de sus
ahora el objetivo de la justicia es
asegurar que semejante suceso no se
repita y sin embargo cinco años después
cada club cada restaurante cada
discoteca de rumanía funciona
exactamente de la misma manera de alguna
medida preventiva contra los incendios
lo que pasó en el collective podría
perfectamente volver a ocurrir en
cualquier momento
[Aplausos]
en la corte de apelación de bucarest se
acaban de retomar los juicios
por ahora hablan los acusados después
será el turno del procurador y luego el
guardia
la meta para adrián algo y para los
demás es obtener por fin la condena de
los responsables para evitar nuevas
situaciones como la del club colectivo
hay que entender que es el primer caso
en el que personalidades públicas de
rumanía como un ex alcalde unos
funcionarios son considerados culpables
por lo que pasó y además de no por estar
involucrados directamente sino por no
haber hecho suelo abajo por haber
violado la ley y por no hacer lo que
debían hacer cinta country and the
people that no había tratamiento en el
hospital los heridos tuvieron que ser
enviados al extranjero para ser curados
tal vez que el docente
a una directiva europea había dicho que
en caso de emergencia los países debían
ayudarse entre ellos y aquí eso no se
respetó durante el bataclán una semana
después francia pidió telford
al día en albú quisiera ir todavía más
lejos y llevar a juicio al sistema de
salud responsable según él por la muerte
de decenas de heridos del colectivo
entre los cuales está su hermana
hasta donde llega la responsabilidad del
estado
[Música]
rush valuta que es uno de los tres
periodistas de investigación de la gas
del texto que reveló los pormenores del
caso colectivo
el periódico percibió rápidamente que
varias víctimas murieron en los
hospitales no de manera inmediata a
causa de sus heridas sino por
complicaciones relacionadas con
infecciones intrahospitalarias
en diciembre de 2015 una primera fuente
nos dijo si tiene razón o direcciones
pero saben por qué porque los
desinfectantes están diluidos por
nosotros realmente eso nada a ciencia
ficción era pura ciencia ficción
[Música]
curso
la gas de despojo investiga entonces
sobre la gestión de los hospitales y de
la industria farmacéutica descubre que
la empresa xxi forma el mayor productor
rumano de antisépticos ha suministrado
durante años en todo el país
desinfectantes adulterados esto sin
ningún control del estado y el asunto no
se detiene ahí we
también nos dimos cuenta que tenían
contratos para su desinfectante en
bulgaria se lo vendieron también al
ejército rumano desplegado en afganistán
parece estúpido y sin embargo es cierto
estos escándalos constantes llevaron a
los rumanos a salir a las calles para
pedir la renuncia del gobierno
un mismo grito de concentración la
corrupción mata sin embargo cinco años
después del caso collective en el plano
sanitario la situación ha cambiado poco
camelia arroyo médica anestesióloga en
un servicio de víctimas de quemaduras es
una de las pocas profesionales en
atreverse a hablar y no lo hace sin
correr riesgos
cortaron hasta el informante del
hospital en forma con quien hablo y qué
hago
hoy en día su balance es categórico solo
hubo cambios superficiales
un surco pasamos de 10 camas para las
víctimas de quemaduras a 23 en el país
por su parte los microbios invisibles
siguen aquí no hubo cambios profundos
hh
de chi
el 14 de noviembre se declaró un
incendio en un hospital comida en el
noreste del país probablemente la causa
de un cortocircuito murieron 10
pacientes
en 30 años el estado rumano sólo ha
construido un hospital en todo el país
para carmen usca tú y johana giorgio les
tomó tres años construir el suyo en
bucarest
en unos cuantos meses las dos militantes
comunitarias recaudaron 30 millones de
euros de fondos privados para edificar
este centro para niños que sufren de
cáncer
se convirtieron en heroínas nacionales
junto con sus equipos tienen otra visión
de los cuidados
por primera vez en rumanía habrá camas
para los padres
de porlamar 9
porlamar que es para las madres porque
en este momento en los hospitales de
rumanía las madres se quedan en una
silla toda la noche
florentino ayúdame a no soy tan alta ok
en rumanía las habitaciones son
demasiado pequeñas y no hay baños en
cada cuarto de hospital por ejemplo en
el hospital marie curie hay 31 camas eso
significa 31 niños con sus madres que
solo tienen acceso a dos baños esas
condiciones hacen que los niños no
tengan las mismas posibilidades de
sobrevivir que los niños de europa
occidental
[Música]
[Aplausos]
las dos mujeres son categóricas si unas
simples ciudadanas son capaces de
construir un hospital
el gobierno debería poder hacerlo pero
el presupuesto de la salud ni siquiera
corresponde al 6% del pib es el más bajo
de toda la unión europea las autoridades
tienen otras prioridades decisión
preparar la catedral desde aquí se puede
ver la catedral por la cual el estado
romano
varias veces la alcaldía de bucarest
entregó millones de euros para la
construcción de gris
se construyen muchas iglesias tal vez
eso no está mal de eso pero también hay
que construir hospitales y colegios
[Música]
carmen usca tu johana giorgi acaba de
lanzar una nueva colecta de fondos para
construir un segundo hospital y para
ellas es innegable la tragedia del
colectivo le dio un impulso a la
sociedad civil
y una convicción compartida por adrián
álbum hace poco he elegido como
consejero municipal hoy se reúne con el
nuevo equipo de la alcaldía del segundo
sector de bucarest antes de la ceremonia
de investidura
es el único sobreviviente del collective
en haberse involucrado en la política su
objetivo transformar una sociedad
todavía influenciada por modelos
heredados del comunismo estoy seguro de
que para ustedes es difícil de entender
porque no conocieron un régimen
totalitario que los o primera durante 45
años para tratar de darles un ejemplo
hay que imaginarse en la vida en las
condiciones actuales con todas las
restricciones actuales y multiplicarlo
por 10 esa fue la situación en rumanía
durante 45 años
that was dominios fortify diers el
alcalde también es un recién llegado a
la política la mayor parte de los que
estamos aquí entramos a la política a
causa del collective
porque creo que nuestra generación de
premios y tragedias como ésta podrían
seguir ocurriendo
debemos cambiar las cosas y buried los
mejores políticos uy
un plato delicioso
en las elecciones municipales de
septiembre surgió una generación de
jóvenes electos como adrián algo a
menudo procedentes de medios
comunitarios y del sector privado
juró respetar la constitución y las
leyes del país y hacer todo lo que pueda
por el bienestar de los estudiantes del
segundo senador de bucarest héctor grito
al municipio el mismo creció
segundo al mando en la alcaldía de
bucarest recientemente elegido vino a
felicitar al nuevo equipo está
convencido de que rumanía está lista
para pasar la página
por estas elecciones municipales
estaremos aquí por cuatro años y estoy
seguro de que lograremos hacer
verdaderos cambios hace 30 años se llevó
a cabo la revolución y creo que es la
primera vez que los humanos no tienen
miedo de ser libres
para esta nueva generación evitar nuevos
episodios como el del colectivo
impresionar a el estado para proteger
mejor a sus ciudadanos en memoria de las
víctimas del incendio una esperanza para
que no hayan muerto en mal
hasta aquí el boleto de vuelta de esta
semana si desea ver nuevamente este
reportaje lo invitamos a visitar
france24 puntocom
[Música]